when I had my kids it was like
that changed everything well the things
you won't do for yourself you do for
your kids and are we protecting our
children the way that we never got to
have that protection right definitely
definitely I hired I hired um it's funny
my kids didn't know they had a security
guard at school I hired someone to be an
assistant PE instructor yeah just to be
there because people were trying to take
them off the schoolyard I had to find
clever ways to kind of make them feel
everything was normal but I needed to
know eyes were on them and not you know
and I was not going to take that chance
I mean your dad and Tommy like teamed up
against the paparazzi and when they're
going after you at The Viper Room and
like I just it at a certain point
I so understand I get it dope with my
kids this is not okay they didn't sign
up for this yeah it's sad it's hard it's
so hard I know I know but you're gonna
get through you you got it you got it
now I mean this is this how did you get
through it because you raised these
incredible boys you have to be careful
that social media and everything and
then there's that layer I'm like oh I
love having kids in this day and age and
maybe our whole lives were the best
things for setting us up as parents we
just have to make sure that women know
how to make themselves safe from very
young girls I also feel like
um anything that you do
that might have put yourself out there
in a sexual way gives you also no
protection right or everything is fair
game no right to privacy yes and that I
probably wanted the attention when the
tapes were stolen and put out there that
they I remember going to a deposition
and they had naked pictures of me
everywhere saying you like this what
kind of sexual positions do you like and
I was pregnant with Dylan and Tommy and
I just said we just have to let this go
the damage is done it's out there and
we're never going to be able to stop it
so Tommy just said you're right let's
just end it also you got to say
something that also I hadn't heard
another woman say which is you know I
don't really know exactly how to love
someone that isn't my kid's dad it's
hard
I know that's hard isn't it
it's just that connection that you don't
have with anybody else and people may
say that they can get past it but I
can't I haven't been able to and that's
okay I don't even care if I'm alone the
rest of my life I've experienced really
wonderful loving moments and sometimes
things don't last forever for a reason
and it's it's okay it's fine it's okay
in the last year I spent alone I think
it's been the happiest year of my life
but I love this discovering of myself
and I just there's so many parallels I
know deal with you and I went I by the
way I went um to the opening night of
Chicago I know you didn't I didn't know
that you were there I've got your
flowers and thank you so much but I
didn't know you were there well it was
probably better you had a lot to
concentrate on you don't need to know
anything other than what you need to do
I love the dedication I loved in the
documentary that you could really see
all the work that goes into that I know
I understand because I get it but like
no one will understand like how much
work goes into it and you nailed it and
I loved it you've opened yourself up to
this next chapter and one of my final
questions was going to be you know what
do you want to do next and so this woman
her name is Tara Watson she did this
tweet that went viral about how you
should join the cast of White Lotus
I've heard that too
um have you heard about this I heard
about it I mean I can't get white I call
it white onion but anyways it's pink I
don't know what anyway I can't get it in
Canada because my HBO app doesn't work
because my Apple ID is American so I
can't get it there so I have to watch it
but I tried to watch it but I heard
everyone loves it and it's crazy and I
think I I mean I'm up for anything so
you haven't really seen it yet no okay
it's definitely one of I think I would
say the only way to describe it is a
masterpiece
really yes it's a masterpiece Mike White
who is writing and directing it it is a
masterpiece and each season is different
than the other there's a through line
with a woman named Jennifer Coolidge
that's who they're saying you need to be
a relative of hers she was the string
from one to two
um that's not a spoiler it is a
masterpiece and I now want to vote for
that too
I really do like I said something great
is just around the corner would you be
okay I don't know I don't know I mean I
just feel like this is this is a it's
such an interesting time I just kind of
want to see what I I would love to do
something like I said when I did
Broadway I just wanted to know what I
was capable of I didn't know if I could
sing if I could dance if I could act on
stage in front of everyone I just want
to push myself so I think that would be
an incredible Challenge and but like I
said I'm not a I'm not an ambitious
person I just I'm not either I hate the
word ambition yeah you know what I love
I drive in ambition I just love this
kind of you know romance and sensuality
and this kind of romantic kind of
lifestyle that I've you know activism
and everything so I don't really know
what's next but I don't I know I haven't
really had the opportunity to see what
I'm capable of on film yet I cannot wait
to see what you do next this is a
fertile opportune redeeming uh
meaningful uh earned
time for you are you gonna do more
movies
you have to if we could do one together
we could both be in White Lotus we could
um that would be funny I want you to be
a White Lotus I I would do we could be
sisters and White Lotus yeah
should we call Mike White maybe we
should call him oh that's funny I'm
telling you I have to say also why This
Woman's tweet has gone viral and why
everybody's jumped on the bandwagon is
because I think that show
um is becoming a franchise that might be
one of the most respected in this
industry and that's where people see you
wow who would have thought I would we
all would
assist it's true you are so loved and
appreciated thank you
[Music]